[Music]
um so were you going to a masculine
figure yeah yeah my dad but I used to
like disagree with him so much though
when I was younger like maybe like 18. I
feel like whatever he said it just
didn't sit right with me I feel like
who's he's very very traditional though
so obviously I'm Nigerian so we go back
to Nigerian culture of like the
leadership dictatorship of men in
general and I just didn't like the way
dictatorship
I mean I just feel like
um I didn't like the way he would
speak to my mom also and the way he
would like
kind of order her around I see my mom
submissive as well to my father so I'll
just look at him like why would like my
mom I would look at my mom like why
would you do these things for him that's
when I was like 18 but now I'm starting
to understand it a bit more in regards
to like making the female a bit more
feminine like being a bit more
submissive but I just feel like
I don't want to argue again but I just
feel like in general men need to
understand and learn how to speak to
females they want to appreciate I mean I
think women we don't even know how we
like to be spoken to right and and this
is you know a very a very again once you
see it you can't unsee it women like
toxic
this is this is what girls this is what
girls say um and then and then they all
have a toxic X it's like okay if you
don't like toxic why are you sleeping
with toxic
and I I don't know you I don't know you
personally so I don't know I don't know
what you're doing yeah but it's like
there's certain behaviors that are
attractive to women it's like there's a
difference between arousal and
attraction so arousal is like like the
bad boy and attraction is like the guy
you want to take home to Mom and like
every girl wants the perfect mix of both
but a lot of times they don't exist as a
man ever spoke to you and you're like oh
um what do you mean what did you mean
you liked it and he was very Stern with
you have you as a woman not thought oh
my God that I don't know why I like that
but I liked that depending on the
context I feel like like if it's okay
let's not get personal but
no not like that common one I feel like
it just depends on the context if it's
just like
point out rude for no reason I'll just
be like don't talk to me like that but
if it's a thing of like I'm indecisive
maybe yeah I mean and he's just like no
we're just going to do it like this I'll
be like okay but when you say don't
speak to me like that like you said
earlier on that you used to watch you
used to think that about your dad that's
what I'm saying it was when I was young
but where's that where's that kind of
rebelliousness come from
in when it when masculine Authority
shows itself like where do you think
that rebelliousness came from I just
don't think his masculine Authority
though like I feel like you can be
masculine and still speak to females
nicely like I don't know I don't know
do you do you think the CEO of a Fortune
500 company is making sure he talks to
his employees nicely or the Commander in
a war probably not well he probably has
to now because of HR but
for the feelings yeah yeah like like
part of masculinity is just like that
get [ __ ] done
regardless yeah regardless of how you
feel like like instead of oh honey do
you want to do this not do this do this
get that done well a lot of a lot of
what we teach
like the way you say like just demanding
it like it's just a certain I don't know
a lot of a lot of what we teach in the
say the earlier stages like the the
chatting out phase before it gets into a
relationship you know we we teach guys
to be basically like less less
conventionally nice in a way because
like most people contrary to popular
belief you know most people that
struggle with um well I think probably
most the majority of guys really are
actually kind of nice guys or at least
they've they've been conditioned to be
nice guys and that comes through the way
they're talking so you know go up to the
guys you know be having a conversation
with her like a nodding dog like oh yeah
you know so what do you do I work at
McDonald's oh really oh wow that's so
cool you know and it's like it's
obviously it's not cool you know
um but he's just saying that to sort of
count out her supplicate her whatever
right so we say to guys look don't you
know just stop doing that stop being
just massively impressed by everything
she says stop being so damn agreeable if
she says something that you disagree
with say that you disagree with it right
you don't have to go along with
everything you know doing those simple
things and it really does change up the
dynamic and it's not about being just a
complete you know like dick where you're
you're just insulting her because
because like like you said I mean you
can't go too far with it as well if you
go in and you're just like you say
something just ridiculously rude
obviously she's she's gonna tell me
where to go because yeah but there's a
way of
doing it where you're just not being
this complete pushover and obviously
fake kind of nice dude just for the sake
of it you know yeah to touch on what you
said um
yeah I don't I don't think women I don't
think women like
necessarily be spoken nicely and I say
that simply
because when I was out here trying to
get women
I I intentionally was just outlandishly
rude and it just worked for me it just
worked what every time you try to be
nice it just it doesn't work girls
across the board not not obviously not
obviously over the top like I just knew
if I was
but I gave you too much compliment I
always threw a compliment with a slight
hint of like I don't really like that
though right so I'll compliment this but
I won't compliment that and something
like that and it just seemed to work for
me and I just started recognizing
there's a pattern in like women respond
so much in this way but I'm trying I'm
sure you're old enough to know this you
know the same treatment
wow yeah that's what we said actually I
mean keep them keen and the other thing
is nice guys finish loss right yeah
there's a reason why they say that but
there's a reason why they say that yeah
but to answer your question in terms of
um did I grow up with a masculine man I
think
not necessarily
in what I got from let's say my dad at
least at that age whether I understood
it or not was he was doing what he
needed to do
for his partner right at that time I I
didn't think anything with it masculine
or not
um at the age of nine I stopped growing
up with him and so I didn't know what
the relationship looked like where was
that however as I get older
I look back at most of the men and I
respect them more as I get older and so
I'm like oh even though I may have put
negative of you or or let's say for
example in the case of oh someone's just
being really harsh or as I get older and
recognize people only move when you put
your foot down otherwise they're not
doing nothing right and everything
starts to make sense to me like oh I
understand why he was like this I
understand why you did this I understand
what you did it all made sense like as
as I get older in life and this is
something I hope to teach my son because
he's at an age where he feels like being
nice is and I'm trying to get him out of
that and you know in a sensible way of
teaching him like listen it's good to be
nice but you're gonna have to be
ruthless in this world because no one
don't listen to nothing I think my son
said I'm teaching the same thing yeah
and a woman complimented me the other
day and I think is one of the best
compliments I ever received she said
you're a good person with a bad boy
spirit and I was like I like that
that's what you need though really
that's what you want it's that nice bad
boy thing yeah like you know you're
fundamentally you're a you're a decent
guy you know she can feel safe with safe
with you but you're not predictable
you're not you're not a pushover you
know and you've got a bit of edge to you
that's the key thing I think I actually
didn't I actually done it um uh uh
podcast with a woman called CZ Mills
over here right and she was saying she
was saying as a woman that you know
women do like a guy with an edge you
know she was saying that you know the
guys that are I guess Square the guys
that are normal yeah they don't really
get much play and you know we speak
about the 80 of men all the time on this
show and how 80 of the men are generally
just normal average dudes they don't cut
a shape when they walk in a room yes
right they they're the guys that you
walk past on the street that are doing
the the bins or they're at Starbucks or
the ones working on the two and women
generally because of this I've always
said hypergamy on steroids right now
um they don't tend to look at those guys
yes as very masculine and they don't
tend to gravitate towards those guys
yeah yeah definitely well me and James
Tusk are currently and this isn't a plug
because it's closed but we're currently
teaching a course called The Edge
okay all right guys come on if you want
to join the
edgefrancis.com but no me me and James
Tyson got this course we'll probably
well we we're going to talk about that
further down the line but anyway
um and it is to try to teach this side
of things because it because guys will
be like okay right so I've got to go and
approach girls I've got to go chat up
girls and if they can get the courage
together to do that which is you know
you'll take it down to about five
percent of all men we're like oh [ __ ]
right I bet Starbucks is a cute girl
I'll actually go and have a conversation
with her right the guys that get through
to that stage and actually do that then
most of them are just being too too
beige too bland two vanilla and it comes
through everything like how you dress
the way you present yourself your body
language like all of these different
things and it's like you've got to I
mean if you look at people like um if
you look at the classic people like the
tides you look at like Justin Waller and
you know
like like some of some of these figures
I mean yes you know you could say Well
they're quite they're good looking what
are their Jacks whatever but it's sort
of more than that they've got that
attitude haven't they yeah do you know
what I'm saying and I think like a good
at that attitude on a guy adds like two
three point like yeah it does a lot
but yeah like there's nothing like just
that yeah there's there's nothing like a
guy that's like very confident it's a
borderline cocky well people say say
with the Tates for example people will
say with the tights well yeah but you
know they've got money and before the
the apocalypse you know they had these
massive Instagram accounts they got
these Lambos and all these sort of stuff
you know no wonder it's easy for them
but you know you could just tell and I
mean Andrew will say I was getting
action before I was famous before I was
rich and you could just tell me you
could see that do you know what I mean
because they've got that thing and you
know and and most guys haven't that's
the problem I don't even remember when
when you went into the Big Brother house
right yeah yeah and yeah he was on Big
Brother oh wow Andrew Tate was on big
brother and I remember him from the Big
Brother house and one of the first
things on the Big Brother house is that
he came in and he went in and was like
yeah eight of you in here at snakes and
everyone's like what who the [ __ ] is you
you know what I mean your snake you're a
snake you're a snake and they're like
listen we don't even know you just came
in and this is the first thing he said
yeah because I've been watching from the
outside and he just came in and you were
like who the hell is that guy and is
that and it's that type of presence you
can tell he's been like that for a very
long time yeah well he was born he was
born in America moved to Luton
stayed in Luton for for a long time
which is why his accent sounds and I'm
like yeah and then he went back to
America um then now he's in um where is
he living now uh Romania Romania yeah
yeah so yeah it's that like you said
that confidence that men exude that
masculine confidence that men exude and
it has to sit on the borderline of being
slightly rude or like just a bit
arrogant yes there's a level of
arrogance you need to have well if you
look at the dark tried personality types
or psycho psychopathy narcissism and
machiavellianism which is you know
basically being a bit sneaky doing
whatever it takes to get what you want
no psychopathy we we tend to Define as
sort of like reduced empathy like you
just don't care that much whatever
people think right
um and narcissism obviously you know you
think very highly of yourself and people
with those three traits interlinked it's
it's been shown in studies that they
tend to get better results in dating in
related sexual relationships but also in
the workplace you know a lot of CEOs and
those people that have these traits a
very high index so you know it's may not
be pretty but this stuff works most
definitely
you know I was just
on Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible